[Musique]
elle a touché des générations inspiré
des créateurs de partout et aujourd'hui
encore barbie fascinent les enfants du
monde entier qui la grosse maison
d'arrêt avec matt savage et ghost est
jeune je m'appelle que marseille n'avait
pu rejoindre avec ou s'ils né en 1959
avec ses longues jambes sa silhouette
filiforme et sa peau blanche
elle choque c'est la première fois
qu'une poupée représente un corps de
femme parvis c'est une icône de mode
très respectée là dès son apparition
depuis 2000 16000 barbie sont exposés
aux cours mont-royal un billet par les
plus grands designers à travers les
années la barbie originale la blonde
californienne a beaucoup évolué barbie
chirurgien barbier astronautes
elle a exercé plus de 200 profession et
le fabricant mattel mise sur ce côté
féministe pour tenter d'essuyer les
nombreuses critiques
mais pour martine delvaux qui a étudié
l'univers de barbie
ce n'est pas assez je trouve que c'est
un bel effort mais encore vivant quand
on met une astronaute puisqu'elle est
habillé en rose on a dit bon on brise le
plafond de verre mais pas complètement
même avec des poupées plus métissée des
silhouettes - est lancé l'iconique
figurines souffre toujours de son image
superficielle et oisive et demeure un
jouet contre vérités et janry ce que je
continue à trouver répréhensible c'est
que d'une part la barbie ne vieillit pas
à peut-être 60 ans mais le poids une
ride
et puis finalement même si la poupée
barbie peut changer de couleur il reste
qu'elle a des preds les traits du visage
sont ce qu'on pourrait dire caucasiens
malgré le vent de changement et une
baisse du chiffre d'affaires barbie
demeure l'une des grandes stars de la
culture populaire américaine
et si jacques audrey charbonneau radio
canada mon frère